almost nine years ago I went outside in
the hallway in a woman past and she had
a valley along gaion and and I went to a
brother and sister I said can you tell
me she's married and they said no
where's she from they said Yemen sin
never mind said Yemeni people don't
marry Palestinians never mind they said
no no her sisters Maritim make a story
short this was on Saturday in Washington
I went back to New York on Sunday
on Monday I found their parents house I
knocked on the door and I said I'm here
to marry your daughter
so what Santa Mira married daughter
which mice I don't know her name she's
short bring them all out yeah
house there is way to interact with dogs
Jenna right the almost respect right
it's not just this open you know
flirting and doing whatever you want
you finally but why is it it's become
something like towering like
mentioned the fresh pressure in the
homes you don't talk about the next day
on the young boy just explodes you know
it does it the wrong way
woman oh so she gives you're not talking
about warning her about me and of
talking about so she did you know that
fog to some of these trances educating
that sexual education since aware right
is that important how I just want to say
one thing let the brothers and sisters
understand that very very very good and
I think this is a major problem with a
lot of us and we forget one many italic
cut out a lot of our Haspel the person
that has complete reliance on Alonzo
gently would be a sustainer if you're
looking for a husband if you're looking
for a wife ask allah azza wajal first
and well Loyola deal and I hello Allah
will not let you down if your intention
is correct you're gonna get the right
wife if your intention is correct you're
gonna get the right husband I don't care
how allah azzawajal he will manage to
bring you together but Allah Azza WA JAL
will because of Allah wants something to
happen it will happen I don't care what
culture your family from or what culture
her family is from
so believe it or not in the beginning
every person comes and they said to me I
said look Allah Azza WA JAL gives you an
appointment every day and the last third
of the night frenzy Louie rosamma
dunya Allah Azza WA JAL descends to the
heavens in a new zulia to confirm
economy that is relevant Allah Azza WA
JAL vehicle hell min mr. Faron
astaghfirullah
is there someone seeking forgiveness i
forgiven him helming type in a to where
they were held in the Hodja
is there anyone medical Muruga
comes out in the last load of the night
and ask you the king of all Kings is
there anything he want
oh lewb maybe you are back well me on
Mac the hearts of my father and your
father a bayonet
asabi outright man between the fingers
of my surgeon he will make your mother
or your father loves your future husband
or loves your future if the intention
behind it is clear because the only
purpose of marriage is for you to get
your husband husband to get you to go to
Jannah and for your wife to help you get
to Jannah so if the intention behind it
is pure Allah Azza WA JAL will make the
means
so if you left up your hands when Rasool
Allah saw salem said in
not metal oome that the mercy of a
mother on her child in Lance area are
hamari beti Mohamed O'Mara one idea from
the rhyme of the mother of our children
do you think Allah when you put your
hands up and you say Allah whom as
opening so just saw her all I give me a
righteous wife
you think Allah will turn you down of
course not you think I'll hammer him in
will turn you down you're asking for a
righteous husband that all you want is
to turn you to Jannah and help your
agenda and make you in turn your house
into a beautiful house Allah will never
turn you so that's number one and
foremost answer to all of our problems
not just marriage turn to Allah in the
last third of the night let's get up in
the middle of the night when we have the
time and make dua to Allah secondly as
far as getting a culture differences or
I am like the chef said I had a ship
that told me I should not marry her
because she's from Yemen and sometimes
my wife will be lucky a legal marriage
t-shirt killing me about her Iguala
correct now like it's a now Allah and
then my mother obviously don't like this
you know why is your kids in better in
the same para you can have the problem
it's going to happen every culture
Abdullah venomous it said Lyle a vitamin
husband along as I said no house would
be empty of sadness you think my houses
is all filled with with the joy or type
I know it look like but sometimes we
have problems so that the house of Allah
Salih Saleh bando Sahaba
so with that I see they don't think that
there'll be a perfect home you're always
going to have problems at home but ask
Allah Azza WA JAL to sustain you and
he's the best of sustainers the younger
sibling and therefore my anyone's my
brother sisters is how I encourage that
to learn more about yourselves
and to return to the right modeling
every member of the family has that
ability in that role even without
opening their mouth just to to live the
righteous life to model it
everybody has eyes and ears they're
watching they're listening and they know
right from wrong so I know that for a
younger sibling it's very hard to tell
his or her other siblings what to do but
without saying anything to them just by
modeling it living it you know praying
in front of them reading Quran you know
having good manners dealing with them
in a very you know respectful way it
just puts them in their tracks and same
goes with dealing with other people you
know when the sisters if it is at school
or at work they deal with non-muslims
even those who don't behave well you
find them all of a sudden restricting
their behavior because they're now
dealing with you you are in control of
the situation
so I don't want you to worry as a
younger sibling that oh if I open my
mouth they're gonna you know put me down
no don't it's not your responsibility
but to model your Islamic behavior
change
devices iPhone responsible you know
different devices parents watching
should they be allowed with the phone
absolutely we all know the story of the
scholar when a young man came over and
to try to learn something from him he on
the first day he had put a mouse inside
a box and in the the box was sealed so
he had told him to deliver this mouse to
another person so I'm the way the
curiosity was just killing this young
man he he was hearing all these things
like what is this inside this box so it
opened it up on the way and eventually
the mouse just jumped off right so he
came back and he was like you know is
this the man I like I'm trust you and I
want you to take this he's like is this
that manna that you given me you know I
told you I want to become a student you
know I want to learn from you and you
give me a mouse to deliver to someone he
said if I could not trust you we told
him to just deliver this mosque is box
to this other scholar and just keep it
closed he said if I could not trust you
and small things such as a mouse how do
you want me to trust you on the end of a
lion so it just and secondly another
teacher told the students every one of
them to take this chicken and slaughter
or somewhere where no one can see can
you see me yeah because these are my
boys from Alabama's I have to
I love these voice I'm modern and yet
and they came all the way from Alabama
Eliza Waddell reward them for the long
drive so I one student came back and he
didn't slaughter the chicken he said why
did you not he said you told us to take
it somewhere where no one can see us and
Allah Azza WA JAL is the old sink so I
couldn't so the the teacher was shocked
so point being made establish a sin and
taboo the lucky and the kettle offal
EMTALA vanilla established the trust in
our masjid allahi and in chicago and we
did it and before another masjid we did
thing called brothers night out and i
would come and I would just go lay down
I would leave the center and I said I'll
be back or wake me up for Todd
and there is somewhere from 20 sometimes
280 brothers and they don't leave to go
to smoke drugs smoke cigarettes to do
anything wrong I come back or they wake
me up the message is clean
they played their pool they've done
everything the trust was there I tell
them one word
alonzo gel I'm not here but Alonzo gel
is there and there is a ribbon at it and
they're writing everything down so
remember Allah is watching allah is
writing and the book will be presented
and your mark lamb so you come back and
they fully trusting give them the device
but established SN give them the
computer let them be home alone and let
them go on a trusted journey not for the
sisters out of town that's something
else but let them be trusted and by
Allah if you establish a sign in them
you're not going to have that problem
well thank you first year he raised the
question of the chicken or the egg but
it doesn't matter you have to always
make sure that your children are doing
what they're doing because they're doing
it for Allah subhanAllah
not for you as a parent and we see a lot
of children obeying their parents or
fearing their parents so they're praying
for that and they fast because of that
as soon as they grow up and you know
leave the home they drop all of it and
say you know I did it when I was young
and I feared you but now I don't care
and that's the risk so you have to
install your children that whatever you
do do it for a logic I know to Allah to
please Allah so even if you're not there
like you just said they are watching
what they're doing because they know
Allah is watching them and you cannot
you know expect the children will really
consistently go just like the police if
the police is not there people speed
people do drugs if the police is there
they behave we don't want to be like the
police we want the children to self
police themselves
it's uh it's a it's a it's a very big
common problem not only in I mean it's
it's in a lot of masada that is
happening from traveling from different
states
it's all over so two things for the for
the youngsters again I want you to
understand well la he my I'm telling you
my my parents I don't want to say they
work to try not to make sure that the
marriage this rhetoric but you know they
were not very happy in the beginning but
III could see the look in my mother's
face like she's going all the way and
then you know the way that we got there
and she was very uncomfortable and I'm
sure now time to live khadijah and fall
team and fara hand you know what I've
been a good wife and helping me where
I've got my man handle about the
Murcielago gel so I'm sure her view is
different the point again if Allah is
Zoe Jenna but first worry about making
sure that Allah and you making a
staccato and ask Allah all along if this
is good for me then oh Allah make if
this is good for me make this marriage
work
so again if Allah Azza WA JAL want for
this marriage to work and she's good for
you try to convince yourself first and
foremost have the belief that Allah
choose for you now secondly again stop
worrying about your parents first worry
about Allah and if this marriage makes
solidus Tahara if this marriage is bad
for me all law get rid of it if this
girl is going to help make it to gender
bring you closer and I've seen I'm
telling you brothers and sister and they
are meddling them of and they are
working so hard and can you talk to my
dad again and the latest one I've talked
to her dad and I talked to the mom
because she was a
Arab and the kid was Indian and if I was
like you know I I'm not that going to
happen and I'm so on so and he's so and
so and after I convinced the dad guess
what the marriage didn't work she just
got a divorce
sadly Sahara if allah azzawajal wants
for the marriage to work and allah
pleased with this marriage and he makes
it easy stop going against bad science
of allah is giving you signs stay away
stay away then secondly about convincing
the parents there is nothing better than
a house that is filled with Eman and
there at either in the house is Quran
and the Sunna have teacher parents sit
them down and reason with the moma class
with something that is measured with
Keita balance in the Torah soon the
problem our houses is not measured by
kita Bala senator Russell anymore it's
measured with what with what just like
they told the brahim and the rest of the
privates and mohammed salah salem that
we want to deal with the religion of our
fathers and great-grandfather's we want
to stuck in their own ways if we go back
to in the house to have the quran i was
our constitution applying everything
there that will happen when how is that
going to happen
like mamas earlier said you acting like
a role model muslim by KO dua Allah Azza
WA JAL will bring the tranquility
announced and you as a good Muslim in
your house allowed bring the peace in
there so three points again one please
in Allah Azza WA JAL and most
importantly asking Allah Azza WA JAL
solitary Sahara Luba nabina Assad man
our hearts is between the fingers of
allah azzawajal if Allah chooses he will
make you marry this woman no matter how
much your parents disliked her or alonzo
it didn't make you marry this man no
matter how much your parents disliked
him so Allah willed for you Allah will
have it number two marry them for the
wrong oh man who need to go take a break
chef you're making me nervous
married them for the right reason that
the wrong reason and that's not for the
looks don't go for the looks go for the
Deen go for the Dean also I seldom said
that tomorrow Batwoman will be married
for four and also I seldom said forbid
that to Dean look for the one with the
religion not mean and Muslim ask her
come here sister would he know about
Quran one was also Selim born tell me
the names of the mothers of the
believers and the same thing as the
brother don't just ask him
are you Muslim or do you just pray I
want you to ask him about his Deen you
know some of the brothers don't even
know what - mmm is how is he going to be
your mmm and how is he going to lead you
to join now you really want to love
forever and for eternity you want him to
take you to Jen and not just here so you
want a man that knows the Dean so number
two is you want to make sure that you
follow a solo science element all gonna
be Deena a man comes to you except his
Dean Dean I mean in Islam below or
Holika Latino his religion and his
religion and his manners or manners and
religion then marry him to your
daughters so that's the second
measurement and the last and third and
most important thing is for you
conducting yourself in the right correct
manner and with that you'll be pleasing
Alonso general law and make things
easier for a lot like Rob
she had often mistranslated as holy war
the word jihad means to struggle Islam
does not preach violence it does not
preach vicious holy war it certainly
does not condone terror and suicide
bombing Islam preaches compassion
tolerance and justice find the truth
about Islam call toll-free 877 why Islam
or visit why Islam org order your FREE
copy of the Quran today I am not afraid
to stand alone if Allah is by my side I
am Not Afraid to stand alone I am Not
Afraid to stand alone if Allah is by my
side I am Not Afraid to stand alone
I am Not Afraid to stand alone
if Eliza
I am not afraid to stand alone